all right let's bring in Larry Cutler
now you know Larry he's the National
Economic Council director he's with the
administration and Larry so much
pressure on your shoulders to try to
bring this economy back after after a
shutdown the self-inflicted shutdown of
the country first things first the
president's going to make some news
today one of our top trading partners
China what they're doing in Hong Kong
and the way they've been acting with
this virus is going to prompt some type
of White House action today what could
you give us an idea what the president's
going to be signing look step back a
second China has behaved very badly lack
of information lack of transparency lack
of cooperation regarding the virus in
cahoots with the World Health
Organization did a lot of damage and we
know the origin was in China and if they
had told the truth perhaps things would
have been a lot easier for the rest of
the world where tragically tragically
hundreds of thousands of people have
been killed now we are coming to the end
of that which is the good news in the
u.s. regarding Hong Kong Brian the
breaking news this week of course China
is now violating a fifty-year-old treaty
signed by Margaret Thatcher in the late
1980s when she was British prime
minister the idea was one country two
systems'
and Hong Kong was to be a free market
oriented democratic system China is now
violating that by taking over national
concern a tional security people of hong
kong are furious and we will not
secretary state Pompeo no autonomy
anymore for hong kong i'm not going to
front run the president president will
be out with some ideas to hold the China
accountable frankly the US government is
I'll use the word furious at what China
has done in recent days weeks and months
they have not behaved well and they have
lost the trust I think of the whole
Western world well they certainly have a
lot of explaining to do Larry I
understand later today there at the
is going to be an economic roundtable
what do you hope to accomplish we'll be
talking with leading CEO Steve covering
the waterfront you know the things are
looking better okay now we are still in
the pandemic contraction we probably
haven't peaked in unemployment and the
numbers coming in in the weeks ahead are
going to be very poor here in the second
quarter it's a lot of hardship a lot of
heartbreak okay a lot of anxieties so it
certainly isn't over
but-but-but-but I will say this the
virus is flattening and coming downward
the openings are coming across the
country businesses are opening new
business applications are opening
there's there's kind of a list Steve of
all the you know I call them glimmers of
Hope and growth cars are driving more
gasoline prices are up the Apple
mobility index is up we're even seeing
on the unemployment claims which is a
terrible number close to 40 million but
it is slowing in its increase so there's
some hopeful signs and I think we're
going to move strong into the second
half of the year with perhaps as much as
20% economic growth will talk about this
with the business leaders and next steps
on economic policy you know we've gone
through the liquidity phase now we're in
the reopening phase I think the next
phase has to go back to old-fashioned
Trump anomic s-- cutting taxes
deregulating fair trade deals things
that grew the economy rapidly in the
first three years plus and things that
can grow the economy rapidly in the
second half and on to next year
president rebuilt the economy can do it
a second time we'll have this whole
conversation with the CEOs and the
others you mentioned next steps the
Small Business Administration and the US
Treasury has set aside now ten billion
dollars in payroll protection program
funding set aside for Community
Development financial institutions what
can you tell us about that and what do
Americans need to know about it well I
think that on that point it's a question
of trying to pick up the lower rungs of
the ladder if you will the bottom
quintile
I'll hit the most the smallest
businesses hit the most community banks
by the way have stepped up they've done
pretty well
we've issued I don't know close to six
hundred billion dollars worth of loans
for all the sniping I think the program
constructed by Secretary of minutiae has
done very very well
so this just adds to that there may be
some technical changes in congressional
legislation to extend the life of the
loans maybe as many as twenty four weeks
we'll take a look at that but it's a
hopeful sign I mean the key point here
we've got them we've got to reward
individuals for coming back to work
that's point number one there will be
some kind of reemployment bonus we're
not going to go to the $600 that's a
disincentive to work the Plus up that
doesn't work but we'll have a better
idea the president still wants a payroll
tax cut for working people that'll give
them an increase in take-home pay we're
looking at this is expensing capital
gains we want to bring people home from
China supply chains
you know you've all learned the hard
works time is not reliable and we want
to help them with some incentives to
come back home to America alright Larry
Kudlow we thank you very much